yes yes it does
all right today's is gonna be really
hard
we're gonna get through it together okay
we're gonna make him proud we are not
gonna let them win who's them the
terrorists honey I sorry but you
understood
[Music]
do you think it's fair that I get to
have his chain and Casey doesn't I I
don't even think she knows what's going
on
you're good
you know
do you think we should we should tell
her we could tell her I'm her dad
you think she'll find out what happened
nah
so late
foreign
hey do you need a Xanax I've run up for
everybody
and married
[Music]
we come together
for this momentous occasion to remember
that even in our darkest times there is
always Joy
there is always light not
wait
here
I heard what you said it was hysterical
but don't talk like that this is a house
of God watch your freaking mouth
there's always Joy
looking good okay
all right little man I'm gonna need you
to smile for the camera
come on help me out here
what's your problem his father died last
week
take the picture yeah take the picture
[Music]